trina and tawanda season seven of
braxton family values is upon us
i feel like it's gonna be a tough season
we've got the pandemic looming over it
we've got the call for racial justice
looming over it
and we have the situation with your
sister tamar
how are you feeling about season seven
no one can know
when when something like mental illness
uh
will move or will surface you know um in
spite of the season you know this is a
real situation that's happening for our
sister
and we we definitely touched on how it
affected us
individually and collectively as a
family but we do not
in any way shape form or wise tell
tamar's story for her
that's only something that she can tell
i want to dig into some
some of the stuff there and i i'm sorry
if this feels a little tamar heavy to
start but i feel like we just got to get
it out of the way and say the piece and
and then get into the let's do it bryce
all right
this the season opens with a flash
forward to you guys finding out
that tamar attempted suicide
wait wait wait i can't wait one more
time i'm sorry what oh i'm sorry
i gotta go like right now i was stunned
and really numb there was no way to
prepare for this
talk to me about the family's decision
to go ahead and put that that moment on
tv
i think that we would do our fans and
the viewers a disservice if we didn't
talk about it um so when they when the
producers
and the family collectively got together
and said this is what we're going to do
we can talk about how it affected us as
a family
and individually when we found out about
it
and it is something that it's been you
know in the news and on social media
and and people they they do want to have
answers we we can't give them the answer
from tamworth's perspective
but we can give them the answers from
our perspective
and what we can also do is give a voice
to that person that feels like oh my
gosh
i'm in this moment of depression i am
having these uh mental health issues
and i feel like i can't speak out and if
this family can go through this
situation
and and get through the situation maybe
i can too
so we always did this show
to help someone else you know not just
ourselves because we've had our own
counseling we've had our own situations
throughout the show
but as long as we can help somebody
there's a reason to continue on to do
the show
this opening scene is heart-wrenching
it's a lot of direct-to-camera almost as
if you're speaking to tamar directly
we're sisters and i love you more than
life itself just like the rest of us and
our siblings and
if you need me for anything i'm here
it does seem like you're trying to get a
message out to her through that opening
sequence
um no because we have her number and we
saw her a few weeks
ago and we actually had a personal
private conversation with her about
everything that everyone is in privy to
um but we definitely wanted the viewer
to understand that this is a serious
situation and we take it serious and we
respect
anyone in their boundaries of where they
are mentally and emotionally a lot of
doctors will tell you that
you know it's important for that victim
to understand how it how the family
reacted or how the how your loved ones
are feeling
um when you have decided to make that
decision i think that's very important
so you guys are still in contact with
tamar there's not a disconnect there
no we talked to of course we're still
sisters
well i you know i think going into the
season there's going to be those
questions especially
absolutely especially coming out of the
tamron hall interview
sure i was reading social media and you
posted this you know
telling people you're going to come on
the show and you were very upset
that the show was still airing and the
episodes were it wasn't about it
airing it was it was about the
responsibility of mental health
and the responsibility of suicide is a
very serious thing
everything is not for entertainment
absolutely did you guys get a chance to
watch that and what what did you think
about your sister
laying it all out there
yes we got a chance to watch it and it
was important for tamar to speak her
truth and that's tamar is true
tamara has to tell her own story and i
think that's just the
that's just where we're standing with it
we're just respecting where she is
mentally and emotionally and if that's
what she needed to do
to get it off of her because sometimes
you got to get it out um
then that's what she had to do
she said two things in that interview
that kind of stuck with me one she said
she would like to see forgiveness
what would you like to see moving
forward tamar forgiveness
do you forgive them on both sides what
does that mean to you guys
tamar said that it cuts both ways
forgiveness is always key
and i think that as long as you know you
have another day as long as you have
another breath there's always room for
forgiveness there's always room for
another chance
we are sisters we are family we are
still in communication
uh no matter what the world might might
think and even though she blocked us
from social media it does not mean that
we don't still text and have each
other's telephone numbers
i was going to say yeah because she
always blocks us this isn't the first
time that tamar has blocked us
okay and we don't measure our family
with social media we just don't do it
that's not our relationship it's just
what it is the second point she made on
the tamron hall show is
she saw the trailer for the new season
and she questioned
why this would be shown at all and what
the intent was
have you guys had conversations with her
about your decision to continue
with the show without her involvement
tamar's experience with the network is
not necessarily mine or anyone else's
experience with the show
however if we did not address the fact
that it happened people would wonder
why didn't you guys say anything about
what happened so it's kind of like
you're darned if you're doing your darn
if you don't kind of thing
we did not discuss uh where where she is
in her health we did not discuss
anything that would
um disclose anything that that had to do
with hepa or anything like that
we did not disclose any of the
information because it's not for us to
disclose
it's not our story to tell but we
but we do have a story to tell tamar is
able to tell her truth and we have a
right to speak our truth as well you
guys keep bringing it to her truth
versus the truth which i think is an
interesting disconnect so maybe
maybe don't buy in fully to her
perspective of things
well i think all of it is about
perspective i mean she
is where she is and we just respect her
where she
is we just respect it and we understand
her and we're just gonna
love her you wrote the letter from the
hospital it said in part
i feel like a slave to you i feel like i
can't
breathe and you're slowly killing me
you're referring to it the network tv
that was the second letter the first one
i told him that if i continued like this
i want to die i want to kill myself i
can't breathe
and i got a response as you're being
dramatic does hearing her
so publicly share her experience with
the network and really paint this
picture complicated at all how you feel
about continuing with the show or
continuing with the network
you know we really we really grappled
with it we really did
you know because we were like okay do we
continue do we not continue
um but this is a yield sign not a stop
sign
you have to take pause and you have to
really evaluate the reason why we even
did the show in the first place
and that was to show people that we go
through the same things that
everyone else goes through and this
situation is not exempt from it
you know um as long as we continue to
help people we'll continue to have a
show
and if we stop helping people then it's
time to go up the air
including ourselves well this is the
second time
in about as many years that there's been
a big shift on this show
you guys all walked away for almost a
whole season
save for your sister tracy so what does
the future of
braxton family values look like do you
see a future beyond season seven do you
see the show changing into something
different
um at this point i don't think we any of
us really know that
but i think that what we do know is as
long as it makes sense we will continue
filming gracks and family values do you
want to see tamar come back to the show
or maybe
do a new show with her like how do you
feel about
reincorporating her into the world of
the reality tv braxtons
tamar needs to get to a place to where
she wants to do things as opposed to
what we want for her
it has to be what she wants for herself
and if we come to
a place to where we can um find some
impasse to where we can work on
something else
in the future then we will but it has to
be her decision because
we want to make sure that her mental
wellness
is first and foremost a lot of questions
left up in the air i guess then at the
like most of us in 2020 it's just a
continued pattern of that
where does everything go from here all
right well i
i'm glad to know that the family is
still in contact the braxtons are still
the braxtons
and that you guys feel that this is an
empowering way to share this side of the
story yes
absolutely all right let's move on from
the tamar of it all
trina i feel like this season was
supposed to be your season and then 2020
slapped you in the face
the wedding this this covet 25
is working on my nerves so that
and i'll call it kobe 25 because
i feel like i gained 25 pounds and it's
so
horrible and now we have an extra hour a
day for this dagger in 2020
and you know as as long as vaughn and i
are happy as long as we were able to at
least get our wedding in before coving
started
i feel like we're ahead of the game and
to be a newlywed
and quarantined is an amazing thing
so uh we're definitely ahead of the game
but the wedding looks like it was not
exempt from drama it looks like
something major ghost down
why there not talking to us something's
going on with the family
she needs to leave i was just so pissed
cuz you coming at me
i'm not gonna let no one disrespect me
ever there are a few major things that
unfold
the flowers didn't show up
caketastrophies
the whole situation happened without me
knowing
because my sisters kept it from me thank
god tawana can speak more to that
it was just i kept it from her so much
so
that she just found out about it on this
past friday
during an interview so i think that i
did an amazing job
yeah you get a five-star sister over
there yes
because you know it's their day nothing
should impede on their day
nothing i wanted to protect my sister so
that's what i did
the premiere really sets up that tracy
still holds a lot of resentment over
what happened a couple years
ago i still don't like y'all i got some
of the issues but right now is not the
time
what can you tell me about what we're
gonna see between tracy and the sisters
tracy is starting to not only create
boundaries she's giving people
um consequences if they do cross the
boundaries
part of the problem in our family is
this we still
sometimes relate to each other as if we
are still
in an adolescent stage you know we still
revert back to
you know how we were when we grew up and
we have to realize that we can't do it
this way any longer because we
are grown-ups now we have our own
traditions to set
sounds like it's going to be a season of
change for this feeling
across the board from small things to
big things yeah
obviously a lot of heavy stuff this
season but what are you most looking
forward to people getting to see and
experience or even experience for
yourself
for the first time or second time
watching it back i'm looking forward to
everyone seeing the happiness that we
share amidst
all the mess amiss all the disparity
amidst every negative thing that they
see in social media i
am looking forward to to the fans sing
the happy times
you guys are going to see a lot of us
being happy and
laughing and being jovial together and
that's what i'm most looking forward to
the fancy again
[Music]